here's something scary uh I took a
screenshot of this there's no way this
is real this is from the Travis Scott
subreddit discussion I blurred it out
it's lit during
kidus I thought Kus was like a a bander
like a concert or something at first
it's kind of a sick name for a band you
coming out to qu during sex met her at a
bar and eventually went back to mine
decided to play my making moves playlist
already already a lie already lonely and
one thing led to another now in the
middle of the deed wake up was playing
and I got really into Travis voice oh
this is a troll really into Travis voice
and started humming the tune I
unfortunately got carried away and
blurted out it's lit while we were still
making sticky making sticky
ooh making
sticky and unfortunately I got a little
carried away and I blurted out it's lit
while we were still making sticky um he
thinks that was not the best
move she had me stop and explain what
that meant and then left shortly after
is there any way she'll stroke my Cactus
again Ah that's boo I fell for it oh
we're going to talk about Mami man why
did we talk about we did last year right
yeah but what's the deal with it it's
like a scam yeah I mean the dude just
tortures people and no one can ever win
and he offers a cash prize if you make
it through his quote haunted house but
it's him just
torturing people is there a new
development on this though yeah these
YouTubers actually meant to watch this
video they infiltrated Mami Manor they
basically went in and filmed themselves
getting you know like waterboarded with
you know Silly Putty and oh was it like
a hidden camera no so the guy knew that
they were filming yeah I guess so he
live streams all the footage of each
guest on a private Facebook group E and
they hacked that Facebook group so that
they could get the footage but this is
the first time footage of someone being
tortured has been released and how bad
is it it's pretty bad Ben there's one
more entrance to this haunted house
which was
this and there's no real objective to
this St you're not trying to escape
anything there's no task he gives you to
do I'll try one more time all right get
in there it's not like if I tried again
I was going to just like magically be
able to breathe water this time but he
told me if I tapped I wasn't going to be
able to enter the haunted house so I
mean I told you guys I'm not leaving
until at least get inside this haunted
house he just kept doing random things
to me to try and like make me give up or
something like for example he would like
according to Tik Tok Community
guidelines posts that the big harm or
cruelty are not allowed on the
platform wow awesome man and I know what
you guys are thinking are you ever going
to actually be able to make it into this
haunted house yes right now they've
finally brought me to the entrance of
this haunted house I don't know maybe
this is like an elevator or something
right as they were about to send me in
this happened my low battery just come
on on me did yep on this phone I don't
know why that's it so was it actually
scary though scary in the sense that
like you just kind of sign a document
you got some weird dude in his you know
his out house like all right here step
one of the haunted house get naked and
I'm going to waterboard you so yeah like
yeah this it did sound like that right
the guy ah my [__] phone run out of
batteries hold on I'm [__] in your mouth
on a here this is like this Dental thing
makes it look so much
worse so okay so wait he had to get
tortured before he even got inside he
just got water waterboarded yeah his
theory is basically that the man Manor
doesn't actually exist that everyone
Taps out before they go in and did he
actually get inside
no yeah so that's awesome yeah so it is
a [__] scam yeah that's great that's
a good
story yeah that's hilarious the the most
the scariest haunted house doesn't
actually exist yeah it's just a dude
trying to almost kill you yeah yeah I
wonder how many people he has locked up
in his basement and he made me do these
exercises with a 100 lb cement bucket on
my back and then finally he said okay
it's time for you to enter mck man or
Ben you get to finally go inside all you
have to do is escape this coffin while
wearing a straight jacket I was told
that there was four keys I had to find
but I got in there and there was
definitely no keys so if you're thinking
well what's the point of this like what
the heck because in order to escape a
straight jacket you have to move your
arm all the way around your body which a
coffin's walls would prevent you from
making these movements but if this
wasn't a hard enough challenge she
decided to make it even harder on me by
getting a a hose and just spraying it
right up my nose the entire time so it
wasn't really a challenge of like can I
escape a straight jacket it was more of
just like how long can I Endure this
pain of water shooting up my nose I
honestly don't think there was actually
any haunted house for me to go to even
if I was able to escape magically I
honestly think uh yeah that mckm Manor
doesn't even exist
that's so funny it is but the dude
creeps me out that he's just torturing
people in his front yard man the guy who
runs this Mami Manor this is his this is
his worst nightmare yeah just an
overzealous vlogger I'm surprised this
didn't happen sooner yeah cuz that's why
we needed Tik Tok to expose the Mami
Manor yeah I guess and how much did this
cost again what $20,000 20,000 to go do
it so that kid paid 20K yeah I guess I
guess he got his money's worth probably
because I mean not probably not 20K back
but like a lot of people watch
that yeah no this is a scam bro do you
think anyone could sue this guy on the
premise that no not with the waiver you
signed
[Music]
probably why would you pay 20 grand for
this I don't know that's so
American to be like dude dude I want to
feel fear but did he also have any real
clients like how many people has he
charged over the years yeah maybe this
one was just like you he got the email
he's like really yeah oh [__] I okay
he's just making [__] yeah yeah oh [__]
that uh toss that bin on your back yeah
how scary is that huh you scared huh
it's like it's just really heavy H yeah
that's pretty scary right all right what
if you uh why don't you go and crab walk
around and uh I'll put this bag of soil
on your nuts
yeah that's creepy isn't it yeah that's
you're not scared yet what about
this oh yeah that's pretty scary it's
pretty scary right we should go yeah
when he's like get in this straight
jacket we go nah yeah oh I don't like
that one do a different
one yeah or we try to beat it it would
be funny to like be un tortur you know I
think that's what that's what I'm saying
I think that's what that kid was yeah
yeah just dude this isn't scary yeah
it's like people usually tap in like two
seconds and kid just yeah just
overzealous yeah that's all we needed
sooner we just need to throw like a
dumbass like frat kit in there yeah
you're going to [__] what go ahead
man I don't tap for [__] yeah they call
me the tank for the reason you know yo
last year I did a whole keg by myself
that I'm [__] up right now that would
have killed anyone else bro telling you
I'm built different yeah it's [__]
Steve will do it you know the Omega you
know the Omega High house yeah bro that
[__] is three stories I jumped off the
third story onto a trampoline broke
through the trampoline straight onto my
[__] feet no damage
bro that is L I'm literally 200200
walking around right now I am good I am
built different try me bro I [__]
dare
you